well done let me stay zat EEZ salt on
the squash in here now I just hold of
the four portions hey yeah welcome back
what are we discussing the Phil the
other day about having what Coolio
yeah per federal balls is exactly that
have you found them yeah excellent
hey well done yeah you just made the
restaurant yeah another 15 quid by
gaving pushing the specials is given
annex some space to calm down and start
cooking like a proper chef one blue all
a la blue get this one right special
night like tonight yeah with the right
sort of encouragement
you might just pull it off I bet you
[ __ ] do
I'm apologizing now because Alex will
overcook the blue steak again okay
sorry Percy it's hardly dinner at the
chipper er me but it's not bad
[Music]
and the customers are liking it too
[Music]
nice very nice
I never thought I'd say that's all
but thanks to Gavin's newfound
confidence the Letchworth boys have come
good rome wasn't built in a day
but at least I bought Alex kicking and
screaming into the 21st century tonight
it was something a bit different
something a different about all about
the source you know
happy first birthday yeah wait a second
being better then Emily happy with a
dining room yes there's a pathetic
answer that means now I [ __ ] hate it
I've a Stalag to make sure that you
don't get paint brush in your hand again
yes if it's a roll man I'm positive in
front of your colleagues your [ __ ]
brains and eyes up your [ __ ] ass why
the [ __ ] did you take Table six he's
over to Table seven you stupid wanker I
really want them to succeed but I'll
take a lot of commitment and hard work
to make this place a real success
[Music]
[Music]